is going through her Mission checklist
she's the pilot of this helicopter on a
mission today to deliver generators to
remote villagers in Morocco's High Atlas
Mountains
as she takes off the aircraft zigzags
its way through strong winds
when we land major Hakeem dwesh briefs
Rescuers on the earthquake hit areas
requiring attention he leads a team of
Special Forces trained on the most
delicate rescue missions
the devastated area is located 1 800
meters above sea level we are talking
about the toughest Terrain in Morocco
where access is extremely difficult and
sometimes impossible
distraught families show up asking for
help Builders like this have been the
biggest obstacle to the Russia operation
the moment they came tumbling down right
after the earthquake they blocked access
to the main villages in the mountainous
areas now the medical teams have
absolutely no other option but to walk
down the valley and try to climb the
mountains all the way towards the
desolate devastated areas hoping to be
able to reach the victims who still need
immediate help
runs a military Hospital in the city of
Casablanca but today he is on foot
treating the one dead
restaurant
we walk long hours to get to Villages so
we can treat people but at the same time
we check in those who have chronic
health issues we give them medicine we
are also psychologists dealing with
patients who are mentally traumatized
people are still shocked and desperate
for help they're still haunted by the
horrific moments of last week's
earthquake
I cannot find the right words that
describe what happened during the
earthquake as soon as the ground shook
it was dark we didn't know what to do or
where to go
for now people here spend their time
Outdoors they say they don't want to
leave the land of their ancestors
this is how complex
information
this type of helicopters because it's
the land on steep cliffs
transport the wounded to this makeshift
Airfield bigger helicopters will then
transport them to bigger medical
facilities
the wounded are taken to this helicopter
as we fly over the epicenter of the
earthquake the extent of their damage
becomes clear entire Villages that stood
for Generations are now in Ruins
and siwi Village South of Marrakesh
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera